حق الغس مش هيروح حق الغزه مش هيروح
ياح جمع واقل تحتوح حق غزه مش هيروح حق
غزه مش هيروح عملوها احمد مندله عملوها
احفاد منديله عملوها احفاد منديلا عملوها
احفاد منديله واحنا في ار ب خوف ومزله
واحنا في عار وب خوف ومزله واحنا في عار
وب خوف ومزله اطفال غزه بردانين اطفال غزه
بردانين اطفال غزه
عطشانين اطفال غزه عطشانين اطفال غزه
جعانين اطفال غزه
جعانين تقضي على التهجير عايز تقضي على
التهجير عايز تقضي على التهجير عايز تق
على التهجير لازم تبقى اخ كبير لازم تب
اخ كبير بخليهم مساعدات دخليهم مساعدات من
غير اسم وتطمينات من غير اسم وتطمينات دخل
ليهم صحفيين دخليهم صحفيين
دخليهم اطباء دخل ليهم اطباء عايزين خطوه
وفاله حقيق عايزين خطوه وفعل حقيق عايزين
خطوه وفعل حقق عايزين خطوه وفعل حقيقي كل
كلامكم سيكي ميكي كل كلامكم سيكي ميكي يا
مقاومه يا
فلسطينيه يا مقاومه يا
فلسطينيه القاهيره والف تحيه يا قاهره الف
تحيه الهره الف
[تصفيق]
تحيه